13 minute workouts 20 minute recipes 10
minute mindfulness ready to become get
feel on the App Store or Google Play I
grew up eating Indian food often and I
love the rich flavors that go into the
dishes sadly with a lot of takeaways
Indian food often get a bad rap for
being high in calories and extremely
unhealthy well this is not entirely true
when you cook at home you can control
what goes into the dish and you can make
them extremely healthy so I'm going to
share with you an Indian inspired meal
prep which is easy to follow delicious
and nutritious for lunch we're going to
make chicken and fish tandoori skewers
served with cucumber salad as for dinner
we're making a part of light vegetable
curry to be served with rice let's start
with lunch tandoori is such a popular
Indian dish and it is healthy what's
there not to love about it the meats are
often cooked in a clay oven but for this
we're going to use a regular oven I'm
going to use a 400 grams of chicken
breast and 400 grams of white fish you
can choose any other meats of your
choice as for vegan you can substitute
the meat for tofu or vegetables for the
marinade you'll need one and a half
tablespoons of olive oil have a cup of
plain yogurt four garlic cloves roughly
chopped 2 tablespoons of fresh ginger
roughly chopped 1 teaspoon of ground
coriander cumin and turmeric and 1/2 a
teaspoon of white pepper as well as one
tablespoon of paprika and salt to taste
now let's start cooking cube the chicken
breasts into chunks and slice the fish
in a blender add the garlic and ginger
along with a splash of water and blend
to make a thick smooth paste now in a
separate bowl add the blended garlic and
ginger paste along with the rest of the
marinade ingredients oil lemon juice
yogurt and all the spices mix well
marinate the chicken breast cubes and
fish slices
and live them for 15 to 20 minutes for
the meat to soak all the flavors in now
let's preheat the oven to 220 degrees
Celsius after 50 minutes skewer the
chicken with wooden skewers and place
them on a baking tray if you don't have
the wooden skewers you can just place
the chicken of fish fillets onto the
baking tray that is absolutely fine as
well
now we want to bake them in the oven for
15 to 20 minutes until the meats are
golden so I'm serving this dish with
cucumber salad or as it is called
Kitumba salad this is a fresh crunchy
salad that doesn't need any cooking and
can be put together very quickly it is a
perfect side dish what you'll need are
half a cup of chopped onions 1 cup of
chopped tomatoes 1 cup of chopped
cucumber cut a cup of chopped fresh
coriander 1 teaspoon of red chili powder
2 tablespoons of freshly squeezed lemon
juice and salt to taste chopped up all
the vegetables and simply add all the
ingredients into a bowl mix well we want
to chill the salad in the fridge until
it is ready to be served lunch is ready
I love the light laminate taste and
slightly spicy flavors of the chicken
and fish tandoori served with the
refreshing cucumber salad this dish is
high in protein and gluten free each
serving of chicken and fish tandoori
with cucumber salad has about 380
calories and 55 grams of protein now
because the meats are could dry they
make a great meal prep dish which you
can bring it out with you and will last
for a long time if you want to you can
also serve this with roti or basmati
rice as for dinner we're making
chickpeas and vegetable curry served
with a purse Mathew rice curries can be
complicated and time-consuming we're
going to keep it really simple and quick
this easy vegan one pot dish is packed
with flavors from a combination of
spices with its smooth
creamy texture what you'll need are 300
grams of Carens cut into cubes 200 grams
of spinach fresh or frozen 1 can of
chickpeas rinsed and drained 1 can of
diced tomatoes 1/2 a cup of light
coconut milk 1 tbsp of olive oil 1
medium onion diced 6 garlic cloves
minced a thumb sized piece of ginger
minced 1 tbsp of cumin 1 tablespoon of
curry powder 1 teaspoon of paprika and
salt and pepper to taste
saute the onion and garlic with olive
oil until tender and golden brown just
for 2 to 3 minutes then add in the
ginger and all the spices and salt and
pepper mix all the spices together
before adding in the diced tomatoes
spinach chick peas and carrots then stir
in the coconut milk reduce the heat to
low and cook everything together for 10
to 15 minutes before serving don't
forget to stir occasionally so I'm gonna
serve this with a side of my favorite
long grain basmati rice you may also
choose to serve it with roti quinoa or
jasmine rice so what I love about this
recipe is that you can keep it versatile
by simply changing up the vegetables
bins or even add meat into the curry you
can even double the recipe and cook it
for a large family so each serving with
1 cup of basmati rice has about 476
calories all these recipes were keep
well in the fridge for up to 3 days if
you're planning to prep your meal for
the entire week then store them in the
freezer as simply warm them up when you
want to have your meals so when you're
in the mood for Indian food instead of
ordering a takeaway make these recipes
in your kitchen don't forget to give
this video a thumbs up share this video
on with your friends and do remember to
subscribe to my youtube channel for a
lot more healthy recipes workout videos
as well as nutritional tips let me know
in the comments below what are the milk
prep or recipes do you want more off all
the best